- Okay, so what about your childhood?
What's like a favorite Christmas memory?
- Oh, favorite Christmas memory.
I remember one year, because
of me, it was my bright idea.
I'm the creative in the family.
And I put together, I was like,
"Let's have a family talent show."
- Yes!
- And so, I thought I was gonna win,
because you know, I'm
the talent of the family.
(audience laughing)
And I sang "Angel" by-
♪ Angel ♪
- [Audience Member] Anita Baker.
- Anita Baker!
God, drew a blank!
Thanks!
And then my uncles came in
and they blew the roof off the house with
the Temptations song.
- Oh, which one?
- Um...
(in deep voice) ♪ It's Merry
Christmas. Happy New Year♪
Because I have an uncle with the-
why can't I think of songs today?
Say that again.
- [Audience Member 2] "Silent Night".
- "Silent Night", yes!
"Silent Night".
- No one's ever heard of it.
- No. Right. That's a, that's a new,
it's a new song, apparently.
(audience laughing)
- So they, they kicked your behind.
- [Taraji] The killed it.
They totally stole the show.
And it's literally, we
talk about it to this day.
I mean, this was when I was 12.
I'm 53. We're still
talking about this moment.
- Oh God, wait!
Wait.
I totally thought you meant you did this
as an adult and you were like-
- No!
- And you were like, "I wanted everyone
to do a talent show
'cause I was gonna win."
- I did.
- And I was like, I was just
picturing you at like 35.
Just like, "I've got my Anita Baker".
(Taraji laughing)
- No!
- [Kelly] Okay. I love it.
It's even, it would've been
better if you would've been 35.
(audience laughing)
So what's one of your
favorite Christmas memories with your son?
- [Taraji] Oh God.
- He's older now, but like did he get-
- No, he is grown now, but I
loved when they're little bits.
- You know, when they're
little, little, little, because-
(audience sighing in happiness)
But you know, that's my baby.
He's so grown now,
and that was, I produced
that play on Broadway.
"Jaja's African Hair Braiding" yeah.
(Kelly and audience applauding)
(Taraji giggling)
- [Kelly} That's awesome.
That's so awesome to
see his mama killing it.
- Yes!
He was so proud.
He really was proud.
- It is. I have the young age still,
so it is kind of still fun.
- [Taraji] It's fun!
- Because, you know,
I think we have more fun than they do,
like putting the toys
together the night before.
But my son was funny.
He liked what he liked.
So he would pick like two or three things.
I swear, I think I picked the
wrong baby up at the hospital.
(audience laughing)
But he would pick like four
toys and that's all he wanted.
And I would buy him like 12, thinking,
"He wants this, he wants this!"
- This is me with my children!
- He hurt my feelings,
because I would watch him open the gifts
and he would be like, "Eh. Oh."
And he would get those four
gifts that he asked for,
grab those up and go in his room.
And all the other stuff I
bought is just sitting outside.
- I can beat this. I can beat this.
My kids don't even open them all!
(audience gasping and giggling)
There's not that many, like,
you know what I'm saying?
(Taraji sighing)
They will literally open, once they find
something they like, they
just go play with it.
- [Taraji] They're gone.
- And I'm like, "I'm sorry, I spent a lot
of time doing this."
- [Taraji] Exactly.
- Yes.
- Like, I'm like-
- These kids, they're so privileged.
- I'm like, "What?" Yeah.
They do not know what it's like.
Anyway, let's- and we worked
hard for that, but whatever.
Let's get into a- there's a
lot of therapy here needed.